sag mal riesa als ich eingezogen
da habt ihr irgendwas von von regeln
erzählt und die für alle in der regel
gelten sollten richtig montag geht einer
von uns lebensmittel einkaufen und naja
du warst nicht einkaufen obwohl du dran
gewesen wärst im krieg ist nicht mehr
zumindest nichts das man noch essen
könnte
es gibt kaffee ich finde das nicht
witzig sommer es ist mir egal was du
sonst so machst die dinge die alle
betreffen solltest du bitte erledigen
lassen vom streber nicht sagen und seine
versager wie du dir erst recht nichts zu
melden
was ist denn hier los findet dazu eine
tage
du hast du ein problem weniger
alex hat mir ein praktikum in seiner
neuen agentur angeboten event-marketing
klingt gut und das musst du genau machen
keine ahnung aber das ist auch egal
hauptsache ich habe endlich einen
praktikumsplatz bei euch alles in
ordnung
mit alex als chef wird es bestimmt
besser klappen als im weißen holunder
kommt das denn
weil er nicht so schlecht gelaunt ist
wie wind sind oder du wieso ich zuletzt
ständig seine laune an mich aus das
nervt das heißt an mir
ist so bescheuert was ist denn mit dir
los
mein freund ist so bescheuert so richtig
jetzt immer drücken
besser ein bisschen danke
da kann super zeichnen und ich brauche
in führung schaffe ich es nie meine
kollektionen drei wochen abzugeben
aber er drückt sich mal wieder davor ich
habe mich auch schon gewundert warum er
denn nicht bei einem umzug geholfen hat
beim super klar dass er nicht kommt ja
meine mutter das geht gar nicht
sie verstehen sich nicht man musste
bisher gegen alle meine freunde was
hilft das finde ich auch doof ich könnte
doch helfen das brauchst du nicht doch
natürlich ich helfe dir gerne und glaub
mir ich bin absolut talentiert